pero por dentro soy bien inglesa, por eso la gente me irrita.
(Risas)
Es verdad.
Lo cierto es que mi familia árabe procede de Yemen
y yo sabía que ese canal, Bab-el-Mandeb,
no es tan difícil de cruzar.
Siempre me hice esta sencilla pregunta:
si los descendientes del mono del Nuevo Mundo cruzaron el Atlántico,
¿por qué no pudieron los humanos cruzar ese diminuto estrecho de agua?
Lo que pasa es que Yemen,
comparado con Europa, por ejemplo,
ha sido tan poco explorado que fue considerado territorio casi virgen.
Ese hecho, además de su ubicación, hizo que el potencial para la exploración
fuera, precisamente, lo fascinante.
Y tenía un montón de preguntas:
¿cuándo se empezó a usar el estrecho de Bab-el-Mandeb
y qué especies humanas, además de la nuestra, llegaron a Yemen?
¿Podría existir alguna especie que la ciencia aún no ha descubierto?
Pero no fui la única que advirtió el potencial de Yemen.
Algunos académicos mostraron interés,
pero lamentablemente desistieron por la inestabilidad política,
y allí decidí participar yo.
Mi propósito era encontrar cuevas.
¿Por qué cuevas? Porque eran los terrenos originales más codiciados.
Pero, también, porque si buscamos fósiles en un clima tan cálido,
el mejor lugar donde se preservarán siempre será en una cueva.
Pero luego, la situación en Yemen se complicó seriamente
y, a pocos días de mi vuelo hacia allí,
la guerra civil recrudeció y llegó a ser un conflicto en la región.
Bombardearon el aeropuerto de la ciudad
y se prohibió la circulación aérea sobre Yemen.
Ahora bien, mis padres tomaron una decisión antes de mi nacimiento:
que yo naciera en Gran Bretaña.
Yo no tuve participación en la mejor decisión de mi vida.
Y ahora...
los familiares que tuvieron suerte pudieron escapar,
y los otros...
los otros sufren bombardeos
y envían mensajes por WhatsApp que nos amargan la existencia.
Esta guerra lleva ya cuatro años.
Son ya cuatro años que causaron una crisis humanitaria.
La gente pasa hambre allí,
una hambruna causada por el hombre.
Causada por el hombre; no es de origen natural.
Es pura y exclusivamente causada por el hombre.
La ONU advierte que podría ser la peor hambruna de los últimos 100 años.
Esta guerra me ha dejado más claro que nunca
que ningún lugar, ninguna persona merece ser dejada de lado.
Entonces me conecté con otros grupos y empezamos a trabajar en conjunto
en otros lugares inestables.
Pero yo estaba desesperada por volver a Yemen,
porque allí están mis raíces.
Y entonces empecé a pensar en algún proyecto para hacer en Yemen
que me permitiera mostrar lo que estaba pasando allí.
Pero todas mis ideas caían en saco roto,
o implicaban un alto riesgo, porque, seamos sinceros,
casi todo Yemen es peligroso para quienes vienen de Occidente.
Pero luego me enteré de que Socotra, una isla yemení,
era un sitio seguro una vez que llegabas allí.
De hecho, ya había algunos académicos locales y extranjeros
que trabajaban en el lugar.
Eso me entusiasmó enormemente,
porque observen la proximidad de Socotra con África.
Sin embargo, no teníamos idea de cuándo habían llegado los humanos a la isla.
Pero para quienes conocen Socotra...
Bueno, es posible que la conozcan por una razón totalmente distinta.
Quizá la conozcan como la Galápagos del océano Índico,
porque es uno de los sitios con mayor biodiversidad del planeta.
Pero también nos enteramos
de que ese medioambiente tan delicado y sus pobladores
estaban bajo amenaza,
en una situación crítica, tanto en la política de Medio Oriente
como en el cambio climático.
Y de a poco fui madurando la idea de que Socotra era mi proyecto en Yemen.
Decidí entonces conformar un enorme equipo multidisciplinario.
Decidimos cruzar el archipiélago a pie, en camello y en embarcaciones de vela
para hacer un control sanitario en la zona.
Se había hecho solo una vez, en 1999.
El problema es que organizar esto no era nada fácil.
Necesitábamos imperiosamente hacer un reconocimiento de área.
Para quienes no lo saben,
es como una expedición para reconocer el terreno.
Y suelo decir que una expedición de grandes proporciones
sin reconocimiento previo
es como una primera cita sin antes haber espiado al otro en Facebook.
(Risas)
Es decir, se puede; pero ¿conviene?
Percibo muchas risas cómplices, pero sigamos adelante.
Por suerte, el equipo de reconocimiento ya había estado en estos sitios inestables,
lo cual, a decir verdad, tenía su importancia
porque intentaríamos entrar a un lugar entre Yemen y Somalia.
Y luego de pedir lo que pareció un millón de favores,
incluyendo al vicegobernador,
finalmente nos pusimos en marcha.
Eso sí, en un buque de madera que cargaba cemento
y atravesaba zonas de piratas en el océano Índico,
con este baño.
(Risas)
¿Lo ven bien?
¿Saben cuál es la peor experiencia que se puede tener con un baño?
Bueno, nunca había nadado con delfines.
Directamente les hice caca encima.
(Risas)
Por otro lado, descubrí que estresa significativamente menos
andar entre mares de piratas que estar...
en medio de una invasión de cucarachas, tan multitudinaria
que, cuando fui a la cubierta inferior,
el piso entero era negro, y se movía.
(Lamentos de la audiencia)
Para dormir, había tres plataformas elevadas
para 14 miembros en total.
Si dormías en una de esas plataformas,
había que soportar solo algunas cucarachas en la noche.
Pero si te tocaba el piso, que la suerte te acompañe.
Ahora bien, yo era la única mujer del equipo y del barco,
así que me salvé de dormir en el piso.
Hasta que la cuarta o quinta noche,
Martin Edström me mira y me dice: "Ella, creo firmemente en la igualdad".
(Risas)
Estuvimos a bordo de ese buque cargado de cemento durante tres días,
y luego fuimos divisando la tierra poco a poco.
Después de tres años de intentos fallidos,
finalmente llegaba a Yemen.
No hay sensación más fuerte que empezar una expedición así.
Ese momento en que uno salta del 'jeep'
o mira desde la embarcación
anuncia que existe la posibilidad, remota pero real,
de que estás a punto de descubrir algo
que puede complementar o cambiar lo que sabemos de nosotros y nuestros orígenes.
Esa sensación es absolutamente única,
una sensación que tantos científicos tienen,
pero casi nunca en sitios políticamente inestables.
Porque a los científicos de Occidente
se los desalienta, o directamente se les prohíbe,
trabajar en lugares inestables.
Pero el tema es el siguiente:
los científicos trabajan en las selvas,
trabajan en sistemas de cuevas profundas,
se suben a un cohete y se lanzan al espacio exterior,
pero tal parece que trabajar en un sitio inestable
se considera de alto riesgo.
Es totalmente arbitrario.
De los presentes, ¿quién no ha crecido con historias de aventuras?
Y la mayoría de nuestros héroes eran, precisamente, científicos y académicos.
La ciencia consistía en investigar lo desconocido.
Implicaba una exploración del mundo, aunque hubiera riesgos.
Por eso, ¿desde cuándo se empezó a aceptar que hacer ciencia es difícil
en lugares inestables?
Y aclaro: no digo que todos los científicos deban lanzarse
a trabajar en sitios inestables.
No es un llamado para ir todos a la carga.
El asunto es este:
a quienes han investigado, conocen los protocolos de seguridad
y están capacitados,
no los detengan si quieren ir.
Además,
solo porque una parte del país está involucrada activamente en la guerra
no significa que todo el país lo esté.
No digo que debamos ir a las zonas que están en guerra.
Pero el Kurdistán iraquí es bien distinto a Faluya.
De hecho, a pocos meses de mi ingreso frustrado a Yemen,
otro equipo me invitó a trabajar.
El equipo del profesor Graeme Barker trabajaba en el Kurdistán iraquí,
y hacía excavaciones en la cueva de Shanidar.
Hace algunas décadas, en esta cueva,
se había descubierto un Neandertal al que se llamó "Shanidar 1".
Para la serie televisiva de la BBC, generamos la imagen de Shanidar 1.
Les presento a Ned.
Ned, el Neandertal.
Ahora les diré qué es lo fascinante de Ned.
A este hombre, Ned,
lo ven ahora antes de sus lesiones.
Parece ser que Ned tuvo una grave discapacidad.
De hecho, tal era esa discapacidad que no hay modo alguno
de que haya podido sobrevivir sin la ayuda de otros Neandertales.
Esto demuestra que, al menos en esta población de Neandertales
de aquella época,
los Neandertales eran como nosotros,
y a veces cuidaban de quienes no podían cuidarse solos.
Pero Ned es un Neandertal iraquí.
Me pregunto: ¿qué más nos estamos perdiendo?
¿Qué increíbles descubrimientos
no estamos haciendo tan solo porque no estamos buscando?
Y, por cierto, estos sitios merecen una historia de esperanzas,
y la ciencia y la exploración pueden ser parte de esa historia.
Es más, diría que pueden contribuir al desarrollo de manera tangible,
y que estos descubrimientos pueden ser una gran fuente de orgullo para el país.
Veamos el segundo motivo de por qué la ciencia tiene un problema geográfico.
Hay una realidad, y es que no empoderamos a los académicos locales, ¿correcto?
Es decir, no pasa desapercibido para mí
que, en mi ámbito particular de la paleoantropología,
estudiamos los orígenes del ser humano,
pero tenemos poquísima diversidad de científicos.
Y la realidad es que estos lugares están llenos de alumnos y académicos
que están desesperados por colaborar,
y lo cierto es que ellos
tienen menos recelo que nosotros por el tema de la inseguridad.
Olvidamos permanentemente que, para ellos, no es un ambiente hostil.
Para ellos, es su patria.
Insisto en que las investigaciones realizadas en sitios inestables
con colaboradores del lugar
puede llevarnos a descubrimientos increíbles,
y deseamos con toda el alma poder hacerlo en Socotra.
Se dice que Socotra
es el lugar más exótico del planeta.
Y con Leon McCarron, Martin Edström y Rhys Thwaites-Jones, lo comprobamos.
Vean lo que es este lugar.
Estos sitios no son ningún infierno, y no deben ser ignorados.
Son el futuro de la ciencia y de la exploración de avanzada.
El 90 % de los reptiles que habitan la isla
y el 37 % de las especies vegetales existen aquí y en ningún otro lugar,
incluyendo este árbol llamado "sangre de dragón",
porque produce una resina roja.
Y hay algo más.
Hay gente en Socotra que aún vive en cuevas.
Y es muy interesante,
porque si, en este siglo, una cueva es una propiedad codiciada,
quizá también lo fue hace miles de años.
Pero necesitamos datos para probarlo: los fósiles, las herramientas de piedra.
Por eso, nuestro equipo explorador se unió a otros científicos,
antropólogos y conocedores de la historia,
tanto locales como internacionales, como Ahmed Alarqbi,
y estamos ansiosos por arrojar luz sobre este sitio
antes de que sea demasiado tarde.
Y ahora...
Ahora, de alguna manera, tenemos que volver
para hacer esa gran expedición,
porque la ciencia...
la ciencia tiene un problema geográfico.
Les agradezco por escucharme.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)